so the latest uh mathematical fact
taking the internet by storm uh well you
may have seen it look let's check this
out there's only if you have seen it
it's been all over the internet i'm
gonna take one divided by
uh
998 000 and what
right if you take that fraction
right what do you get if you uh do the
decimal for it you get something rather
remarkable you get every single three
digit number so it starts with naught
point and it goes not not not that's
zero then it goes no not one there's one
not not two
not not three
not not four
not not five and it will give you every
single three digit number
except for one it doesn't give you nine
nine eight every single three digit
number except nine nine eight okay so
let's let's go on so it goes uh six
seven skip a few then it'll go nine nine
six
nine nine seven
there is no nine nine eight it goes nine
nine nine and then it starts again it'll
go back to zero zero zero and then zero
zero one
and go starts again it repeats
so we had a lot of people emailed us
about this and uh you know one of our
favorite youtubers uh vsauce uh gave us
a little shout out and asked us about it
as well and so we had to make a video
about this we have seen this before it's
not as remarkable as you may think so
this is a repeating decimal
for start i want to show you that this
is part of a family of similar facts so
one thing to notice
is 998001
this is actually 999
squared
now this is why we've got a little
family of facts here because
if i took
1 over
9 8
this is actually 1 over 99 squared same
sort of idea and what you would get are
all the
numbers all the two digit numbers for
that so you would get 0.00
so it's the same idea you get all the
two
digit numbers except for
98 in that case very similar idea
eight 99980 zero one okay it's the same
sort of idea again this is one over uh
nine nine nine nine squared and you get
all the four digit numbers now why one
over nine squared now that's the one i
really want to show you because we want
to make this a bit simpler okay let's
not go straight into it let's take the
simplest example
1 over 9 squared so 1 over 81 that's
what we're going to look at 1 over 9
squared and that will give you all the
one digit numbers
zero point zero one two three four five
six seven
it misses eight
nine and then back to zero again it
repeats that pattern so it's the same
idea so let's achieve we can work out
why this is true and then this will this
idea will work for the other examples
that we've seen so far
right do another piece of paper do you
need another piece of paper let's get
you more paper
so the easiest explanation for this is
that we could make any repeating decimal
that we wanted to make
so if you wanted to make say this now
let's say it's going to start with
naught point let's take some digits
let's call it
a1 that's the first digit
a2 the second digit a3 and let's say
it's
i don't know n digits long and then it
repeats so you get the same thing then
goes dot dot you get that repeated over
and over again
you can make that quite easily all you
have to do to make that
is to take this little sequence
a1
a 3
up to a n and divide it by
the same number of nines you've got n
nines here nine nine nine
whatever number that is
so those two things would be equal for
our example then uh for one over
eighty-one
uh we we wanted uh not point
not one two three four five six seven
nine dot dot dot
zero one two three four five six seven
nine over
nine nine nine nine nine nine
nine nine nine
and that would give you that decimal
representation and that does simplify
that makes a nice
1 over 81. now
you could make any repeating decimal
using that method but there is something
special about that because it simplifies
so nicely makes such a nice number so
not all fractions like this would make a
nice number so why is it so nice let me
try and show you that
so here's a little
formula if you study mathematics here's
a little formula that you will learn
perhaps at some point anyway let me show
you what it is a little little
expression
uh it starts with uh 1
plus 2x
plus 3x squared plus
4x cubed plus right and that can go on
forever okay so imagine this little
equation now here's a little cool thing
if
your number x is less than one
uh in fact this works for negative
numbers as well if they're sort of sort
of greater than minus one what i'm
saying is if the size and that symbol
means the size of x if it's less than
one
this
actually really simplifies to something
pretty cool it becomes
one over
one minus x
squared
and isn't that cool that complicated
thing that goes on forever actually if
you if your x is less than 1
it's the same as that will give you the
same answer that's pretty cool that's
pretty cool isn't it right so we're
going to use this uh to work out uh our
fraction okay so if i let
let's say let
x equal 1 over 10
right what do i get
on this side i'm going to get i think
i'll write it as a column okay i'm going
to get 1
2x so 2 times 1 10
that's not 0.2
and you add them together
this one is 3x squared
which is plus
0.03
plus 4x cubed equals 0.004
and you keep going dot dot keep going
forever
all this on the left is equal to on this
side
if x is one over ten
well i see one minus one tenth is nine
tenths
squared
nine tenths squared is eighty one over a
and because it's one over that fraction
you flip it
this is equal to 100 over 81.
so all this
is 1.23456
equals 100 over 81. the one we're
interested in was actually just the same
thing but just
100 times smaller you just had to shift
it across a couple of places so that's
why you got that such a neat cool
fraction out of that really simple but
why is it missing the eight now that's
interesting why is it missing eight
check this out okay let's go a few down
let's do the eight
not point let me see i'm going to need
six of those
then eight let's do the next one
naught point
seven more
then there's the nine and then if i want
to add ten
where it's going zero try again
point now zero zero zero zero
zero zero
zero now i want to write zero ten here
but there is no symbol for ten i can't
write zero ten i have to write
ten like that now if you add this all
together you just add up the columns
just a column at a time can you see it
carries on
like you learned at school this carries
on so this one plus nine the nine turns
into a ten so that carries on so you get
one plus eight and that becomes a nine
your eight becomes a nine you're missing
eight turns into a nine because of all
this carrying on so all this is like a
like a row of dominoes you get a carry
on carry on carry on your eight turns
into a nine it disappears
and you get that number rediscovered
and the same sort of idea will work for
all those other fractions that we looked
at so the one over nine hundred and
ninety eight thousand and one
is the same idea you can prove the same
thing with the same idea it's really
it's a cool fact isn't it it's a cool
little little fact yeah i like the fact
and it's not completely trivial
but you can make any repeating decimal
that you want to make so that's not
particularly remarkable why does it
suddenly be gone on the internet why is
it suddenly who knows who knows you get
these things every now and again these
things go viral uh
mathematicians can go can roll their
eyes and go oh no not this oh oh yawn
boring but every now and again for no
reason as far as i can see you get this
happening